Haben wir in unserem Sonnensystem einen weiteren Planeten entdeckt,
den bis jetzt noch niemand gesehen hat?
2 Wissenschaftler aus Kalifornien haben die bisher stärksten Hinweise
auf diesen ominösen ''Neunten Planeten'' gefunden.
Er soll 200- bis 1200-mal weiter von der Sonne entfernt sein, als wir selber
und ist wahrscheinlich ungefähr so schwer wie Neptun oder zehnmal so schwer wie die Erde.
♪ Intro ♪
Der vermutete Planet unseres Sonnensystems ist so weit von uns entfernt,
dass er 10.000 bis 20.000 Jahre braucht um einmal um die Sonne zu kreisen.
Die Wissenschaftler vermuten auch, dass ''Planet X'' , wie er genannt wird,
auf einer stark elliptischen Bahn kreist und an den Wendepunkten bis zu
180 Milliarden Kilometer von der Sonne entfernt ist.
Aber: Noch kein Grund zum Feiern, denn alles ist bis jetzt nur theoretisch.
Den beiden Wissenschaftlern sind eigentlich nur 6 Objekte im Kuipergürtel aufgefallen,
die sehr komische Bahnen fliegen.
Nach weiteren Untersuchungen stellte sich heraus, dass ein sehr massereicher Körper, wie zum Beispiel
ein Planet, alle Anomalien perfekt erklärt, da er die Bahn der anderen Objekte beeinflussen würde.
Die Wissenschaftler machen dann, was viele Wissenschaftler mit einer brisanten, neuen
Theorie tun: Sie versuchten das Gegenteil zu beweisen, und scheiterten damit bisher.
Gesehen wurde der mysteriöse Planet zwar noch nicht, allerdings, so die Wissenschaftler,
müsste dies mit heutigen Technologien bereits möglich sein und vielleicht versteckt sich der Planet
sogar in Weltallbildern, die bereits aufgenommen wurden.
Es gibt eine Wahrscheinlichkeit von 0,007 %, oder 1 zu 150.000,
dass die Bahn der anderen Himmelskörper zufällig auf diese Weise beeinflusst wurden.
Das klingt für uns zwar ziemlich unwahrscheinlich, reicht Wissenschaftlern aber im Normalfall nicht aus:
Eine Wahrscheinlichkeiten von 1 zu 1,7 Millionen wäre hier besser.
Deswegen sind auch viele andere Wissenschaftler noch nicht bereit den beiden zu glauben.
Man müsse weitere Untersuchungen anstellen und, im Optimalfall, den Planeten auch wirklich
durch ein Teleskop beobachten können, ehe man ihn als neunten Planeten unseres Sonnensystems erklärt.
Falls der Planet gerade am äußersten Ende seiner Umlaufbahn ist, bräuchte man wahrscheinlich eines der
größten Teleskope der Erde, wie zum Beispiel das
Subaru-Teleskop in Hawaii um ihn betrachten zu können.
Falls er näher an uns und der Sonne ist, sollten auch andere Teleskope in der Lage sein, ihn zu sehen.
Es wäre nicht das erste Mal, dass man Planeten so weit von ihren Sternen entfernt findet:
Das Weltraumteleskop Kepler findet regelmäßig Planeten mit riesigen Abständen zu ihren Sonnen.
Es ist also durchaus möglich, dass es einen oder sogar mehrere Planeten da draußen gibt,
die um unsere Sonne kreisen, und damit zu unserem Sonnensystem gehören.
Und auch die Methode ist nicht neu:
Neptun wurde 1846 nur entdeckt, weil Uranus von seiner berechneten Bahn abwich
und ein großes Objekt ihn anziehen musste.
Die Chancen stehen also nicht schlecht, dass wir bald das erste Mal, seit Pluto 2006 zum
Zwergplaneten degradiert wurde, wieder neun Planeten in unserem Sonnensystem haben.
Und, um sich bis dahin die Zeit zu vertreiben, sucht das Internet fieberhaft nach einem Namen für den neuen Planeten.
Hoch im Kurs stehen weiterhin griechische Götter:
Argos, Jotun, Nibiru und Marduk sind im Rennen.
Ich persönlich wäre eher für was Cooles: Naboo, Aldebaran,  Endor oder wir nennen ihn direkt einfach
Todesstern: Wie cool wäre das denn, dann hätten wir unseren eigenen Todesstern im Sonnensystem.
Wie würdet ihr euren Planeten nennen, schreibt's mir unten in die Kommentare,
bin schon sehr gespannt, was da für Namen bei rumkommen.
Und wenn euch Neuigkeiten wie diese hier interessieren, dann solltet ihr mir auch mal auf Facebook oder Twitter
folgen, denn es passieren jeden Tag so viele coole Dinge im Bereich der Wissenschaft
und in anderen Bereichen, da kann ich nicht jedes Mal ein Video darüber machen, aber:
Bei coolen Sachen halt' ich euch auf Social Media immer auf dem Laufenden.
Also checkt die Videobeschreibung und ansonsten viel Spaß, bis zum nächsten Mal, euer Cedric.